child, whether it be a Palestinian
child, or a Jewish child, or a Chinese
child, or a black child, or a white
child, or any child to be blown into
smithereens because some guy decided he
wants to boost his political career
called Netanyahu before some election.
So, he presses a button and all of a
sudden 200 people die, 250 people die.
Of them,
60 are children.
Nothing funny about that, my friend.
There's nothing funny about that, my
friend. When I say that, 60 children
died, which is 30%. 30% of those who
were injured were children
playing in
Yeah, look at look Yeah, please.
They were they killed themselves.
I'll ask you a question. I'll ask you a
question.
I've been in this Listen to me, mate.
Listen to me. Just Don't interrupt.
If In Israel, there are many Arabs in
prison Yes. for starting with the Jews.
There are many Jews in prison for the
starting of Arabs. In the Palestinian
authorities, there's no not one Muslim
in prison for starting with the Jews.
Okay, fine. day. I am not here to
represent the Palestinian authorities,
with all due respect. I have not said
that the Palestinian authorities are all
good. Maybe they're doing bad things,
but let me tell you something. Who are
the Palestinian authorities? The
Palestinian authorities are
Gaza and a few provinces in the West
Bank. I don't know who's in prison for
that. Do they even have prisons? The
question is this, when I said that the
children were being killed, you know
what this this this disgusting and
despicable man who's a coward. He You
know what he said? He said they're
killing themselves. How can a child kill
themselves? You see that that racist
attitude comes out. It's exposed. He
humiliated himself in front of tens of
thousands, believe me, if not hundreds
of thousands, maybe millions of people.
They're going to see Look at that guy.
He said children kill themselves. How do
children kill themselves? Do they decide
that bombs were going to drop on them?
Do you really Are you in agreement with
them? Yes or no? Okay, don't say
anything if you're in agreement with
him. That's why I thought. Silence is
acquiescence.
Do you think a child that's 6 years old,
7 years old, 8 years old, he is killing
himself? Maybe doing a suicide bomb at
the age of 6, 5, 7, 3?
A baby killing themselves, come out of
the the womb and you know, decide to cut
themselves?
I don't think that's what's happening,
my friend. I think what's happening is
there's political decision-making which
is causing children to die and that's
coming from Israel.
And yes, also it's coming from Hamas. We
don't We don't agree. They make
decisions which also has lives of of the
children are in danger. But why don't
you condemn like we condemn?
Why are you afraid to condemn?
Is Is this the Is this the level of
stubbornness you have? Is this the level
of stubbornness that you say the
children are killing themselves?
Is this the level of discourse that
there is here in the Jewish community in
the heart of London? Is this the
representation you want for yourselves
as Jews? Someone to come, the only man
that had
some Sorry to say the balls. The only
man. And he says the children are
killing themselves.
Oh, what a great argument, my friend.
The children are killing themselves.
Yes, they're killing themselves. I said
children are being smashed and blown up.
He said, "You know what? The children
are killing themselves." What are you
talking about, you stupid man?
What kind of thing is this?
Is this the thing that Moses said? Do
you really believe Moses if he was here?
Wallahi, I say wallahi, which means by
God.
Hashem, Elohim, call I know you're not
allowed to say his name. I know the
Hebrew Bible.
I know.
Yes.
But let me ask you a question. Do you
think if Moses was here today Answer
this question in your minds. I know
you're you're not going to do it out
loud. If Moses was here today and I said
children in Palestine are being
destroyed and the man comes forward, a
Jewish representative and someone who
claims to be Jew. He says they're
blowing up themselves. Do you think
Moses Do you think Moses will say, "Yes,
you're right"?
Do you think Moses? Do you think David?
Do you think Solomon? Do you think he's
he's going to say, "Yes, you're right"?
Wallahi, if you do believe that, you
have disgraced yourselves and your
religion.
You have disgraced yourself. You need to
go back to the Torah. That's why I tell
you all, go back to the Torah. Read it
from the beginning again. Read Exodus.
Read Numbers. Read Read Leviticus. Read
Deuteronomy.
Read Genesis. Go ahead and read it. You
could You haven't read it. If you think
it's acceptable for a man to come and
say if you think it's acceptable in any
universe in any universe for a man to
come and say that the children are
blowing themselves killing themselves,
they're doing it to themselves.
I would be ashamed of myself. I really
would. If a Muslim said that and I
didn't correct him.